[Music]  you've always said mom and I were a gift  from God but you never told me what  really happened why I was afraid that  they might take you away from me just  wanna have a mother everybody's got a  mother  that's another question entirely  I'm not psychic it isn't anything fancy  lights ESP I'm just lucky Bernie had  always told me that I should only use my  luck thank you for a good reason  don't abuse your gift  what about wanting to know if you have a  family out there somewhere  is that a good enough reason I need  somebody buy me a ticket did you rob a  casino I don't think are Heidi to be  Heidi she doesn't do the sinking  [Music]  life isn't always fair  maybe we were waiting for you Heidi we  didn't even know  [Music]  [Music]  person has a right to know they're not  supposed to guess who they are  call in the air heads or tails kiss  again tips  hiss heads that's ten for ten  you  [Music]  you